bonsoir et bienvenue dans ça vous
regarde sur avis de vous retrouver au
sommaire ce soir emmanuel macron contre
les profiteurs de guerre le président a
lâché l'expression cette semaine lors du
sommet du g7 producteurs spéculateurs
qui distille précisément et pourquoi un
tel changement de ton faut-il taxer les
super profits les grandes compagnies
pétrolières et gazières face à l'envolée
des prix quel est le bon niveau pour la
meilleure réponse c'est notre grand
débat dans un instant ce soir avec nos
invités c'est la plus grande arrestation
de masse de juifs en france 16 et 17
juillet 1942 près de 13000 personnes
dont 4000 enfants étaient arrêtées en
deux jours par la police parisienne
notre grand témoin vient de publier un
livre essentiel sur la rafle du vel
d'hiv dont la france s'apprête à
commémorer les 80 ans il présente aussi
dans un autre ouvrage les destins que
cabu avait fait de ce drame son image
l'historien laurent joly est avec nous
ce soir enfin 2 a franchi voyage dans le
temps ce soir avec brando noir est sûre
les différents présidents de commission
des finances ici à l'assemblée puis la
chronique de thibault et locke hier
aujourd'hui demain la contraception
alors vous les américains reviennent sur
le droit à l'avortement voilà pour le
menu ce soir c'est parti
[Musique]
et bienvenue à vous chers
téléspectateurs on le croyait cantonné à
la gauche le débat sur les profiteurs de
guerre est donc relancé à la faveur
cette fois d'une petite phrase lâchée
par le président de la république
lui-même bonsoir stéphane peu un joueur
et merci d'être avec nous vous êtes
député communiste de seine saint denis
las nubes la coalition de gauche emmenée
par jean luc mélenchon qui plaide depuis
des mois pendant toute la campagne sa
foi présidentielle et législatives pour
taxer les super profits des grands
groupes qui se sont enrichis pendant
cette guerre en ukraine bonsoir anne
sophie lcif ravi de vous retrouver sur
ce plateau vous êtes chef économiste du
cabinet de conseil bdo et spécialiste
des prévisions économiques bonsoir fou
dinh nguyen merci d'être là d'être
chercheur sur les politiques
énergétiques françaises et européennes à
l'institut jacques dollars et puis bon
soir philippe chalmin merci d'être à
jour à distance vous êtes professeur
d'économie à l'université paris dauphine
je vous donne la parole à tous les
quatre dans un instant mais pour nous
planter le décor comme chaque soir là ni
blakowski si j'ai bien compris c'est à
lui pour démarrer
[Musique]
bonsoir stéphane on sort myriam bonsoir
à tout bonsoir à tous si j'ai bien
compris ce soir si j'ai bien compris
myriam on s'inquiétait ces quinze
derniers jours à l'idée que la france
soit gouvernable notamment parce que le
bloc mélenchon et le bloc macron
paraissent avoir des positions
inconciliables
merci le suivre mais est ce que c'est
vraiment le cas je sais pas l'autre jour
on a entendu le président macron à la
fin du g7 tenir un petit discours qui à
mon avis aurait pu être applaudie dans
un meeting de jean luc mélenchon on les
écoute des gens qui ont spéculé sur la
guerre et aujourd'hui vous avez des gens
qui font beaucoup d'argent sur les
guerres
on appelle ça des profiteurs de guerre
et moi je ne comprends pas comment on
peut accepter très longtemps que
l'argent du contribuable dans nos pays
soient utilisés à aider les ménages à
pouvoir vivre en temps de guerre et
quelques titres et des gens qui
s'enrichissent beaucoup en temps de
guerre donc on va devoir régler ça
avouez que ça sonne quand même très à
gauche cette manière de clouer au pilori
les les profiteurs de guerre moi je
faisais le parallèle avec mélenchon mais
à mon avis le président mâcon il est un
peu plus radicale que ça je pense qu'il
pourrait prendre sa carte à lutte
ouvrière parce qu'il est exactement sur
la même ligne que nathalie arthaud bah
si souvenez-vous pendant la
présidentielle on écoute il y à des
profiteurs de guerre en ce moment il y à
des spéculateurs il faut quand même leur
damer les dragons pétrolier n'a rien sur
mais bien sûr tous les grands groupes
tous ceux qui ont du poids tout ce
qu'ils ont suffisamment donc de
puissance mais bien sûr que ils peuvent
manipuler les marchés comme ça leur va
bien alors cela dit je pense qu'il faut
mettre un petit bémol je ne suis pas
professeur d'économie évidemment mais je
pense que c'est pas exactement la même
position nathalie arthaud elle veut
exproprier les profiteurs de guerre sans
indemnisation je suis pas sûr que le
président m'a qu'on soit encore prêt à
aller jusque là mais alors comment
lutter contre ces profiteurs de guerre
alors moi je sais pas mais ça va être
mon côté robin des bois la première idée
qui me vient à l'esprit que moi ça
serait de prendre aux riches pour donner
aux pauvres vaches pas d'ailleurs
c'était l'idée qu'avait eu la france
insoumise en 2021 il a fait une
proposition de loi pour taxer les
profiteurs de crise pas de guerre
c'était par rapport aux entreprises qui
avaient fait des gros profits pendant le
coc vide donc ça a été retoquée par par
la majorité mais je veux dire il n'y a
pas besoin d'être en rupture avec le
capitalisme pour avoir envie de taxer
les superprofits regarder le royaume uni
est ce que boris johnson et de gauche my
god non évidemment et pourtant il
attaque ses 25% les grosses entreprises
qui fait très beau et gros bénéfices sur
l'énergie dont notamment les pétroliers
car pourquoi ne le fait pas en france
alors je vous rappelle que les deux
lignes rouges tracées par le président
macron pour son nouveau - cana sont
premièrement on ne creuse pas la dette
deuxièmement on n'augmente pas les
impôts donc taxer les profits
exceptionnels oui c'est augmenter les
impôts de temps aux dragons du groupe
total qui a fait des débuts des
bénéfices records donc bruno le maire
lui ce qu'il préfère c'est mettre la
pression sur total pour qui baisse ses
prix et que donc l'argent revienne
directement sans passer par les caisses
de l'état dans la poche du consommateur
si je voudrais pas convaincu il s'est à
son tour tout l'effort ne peut pas
reposer uniquement sur l'état et sur la
dépense publique il faut également que
les entreprises fassent un effort total
l'a fait sur le prix du carburant il
faut accorder une remise de 10 centimes
d'euros
sur le prix du litre de carburant qui
complète la remise de 18 centimes de
l'état je suis demandé au président de
total patrick pouyanné de faire à
nouveau un effort alors est-ce que total
a cédé aux pressions du gouvernement
alors quand une fois sans être un
spécialiste je n'ai pas l'impression ya
eu c'est une tribune publiée dans le jdd
signé par patrick pouyanné notamment qui
disait je comprends très bien qu'un
français en aient marre de dépenser plus
pour la carte durant ma ya une solution
c'est consommer moins de carburant tout
simplement ouais d'accord bon si vous
voulez m'enfin ils ont même fait un
petit geste a peur de se faire tirer
l'oreille total ils ont fait une
ristourne de 12 centimes cet été dans
120 stations qui sont les stations
d'autoroute donc on rappelle juste
qu'ils ont 3700 situation dans le pays
et que ça concerne 120 stations
documentaire je pense non alors cela dit
il n'y a pas que les grands groupes
pétroliers 1 qui profitent de la
situation
c'est en tout cas ce que disait michel
edouard leclerc qui lui non plus n'est
pas en rupture avec le capitalisme mais
il disait il n'ya pas que la pénurie qui
crée une station sur les produits
alimentaires ya certains groupes
industriels de l'agroalimentaire qui en
profitent pour justement augmenter leurs
marges donc regarder ce qu'ils réclament
vous allez voir ça une commission
d'enquêté parlementaire mais alors là
mais ça tombe bien mais qui vient d'être
élu à la tête de la commission des
finances mais c'est eric coquerel qui
justement rêve d'enquêter sur ce sujet
donc crois que la conclusion c'est que
tout le monde a priori à les profiteurs
de guerre dans le collimateur je pense
qu'aucun d'éviter de défendra les
profiteurs de guerre comment se mettre
d'accord sur la manière de le faire
plier un petit peu quoi on est là pour
en débattre merci pour votre regard
stéphane stéphane peut on va parler des
solutions concrètes mais l'expression
est très forte elle est politique elle
nous renvoie d'ailleurs la première
guerre mondiale dont les appeler comme
ça allait les grands les grandes
entreprises d'armement à l'époque le
fait le président l'utilisent vous en
féliciter oui alors ils l'utilisent en
parlant depuis l'étranger donc j'espère
qui est de retour en france il reprendra
la formule parce que c'est un sujet qui
concerne notre pays et qui appellent des
mesures dans notre pays mais oui je
reprends je reprend la formule de la
même manière que le même président de la
république emmanuel macron avait parlé
un propos du collier du parler d'une
guerre au début de la crise du comité
qu'il y a eu en tout cas des profiteurs
de la crise du coc vie dont on le sait
fort bien et donc à chaque fois en fait
ce qu'il faut se dire c'est que ce n'est
pas être ultra révolutionnaire que de
reprendre la formule de rosanvallon qui
disait à propos du capitalisme et du
marché qu'il n'était pas immoral mais il
était tout simplement amoral que le
business n'a pas de morale le business
donc s'il n'y a pas une puissance
publique pour le réguler pour l'orienter
pour lui dresser des lignes rouges eh
ben le marché dans son fonctionnement
alors non encadrés non régulé et ben
profite de toutes les situations encore
faut-il que ce soit possible et on
élaborant des macs ont pris quand c'est
le plus amorales comme c'est le cas
actuellement avec liar philippe chalmin
avant de venir à nouveau un sur sur les
solutions concrètes pour traduire au
fond ce qu'a dit le président de la
république est ce que c'est possible ou
pas de réguler les prix de l'énergie ou
des matières premières est-ce que vous
pensez que ce changement de ton
s'adresse davantage aux français où
c'est le président du g7 qui essaye de
te taper du poing d'audard table comment
vous l'expliquez ce changement de ton
des manuels macron écouter j'avoue que
de la part de quelqu'un que je pense
rôle est très intelligent et au fait des
choses économiques commeinhes l'annuel
macron je suis quand même un peu surpris
qu'ils ressortent à un vocabulaire qui
frise bon la démagogie et qui
effectivement parle aux français mais
qu'il n'a pas de sens qu'est-ce que
profiteurs de guerre
il faut bien être conscient que oui là
et en ukraine les appelle d'ailleurs ce
que nous avons connu en 2021 car la
flambée des prix de la plupart des
matières premières notamment de gaz et
du pétrole elle remonte à 2021 la crise
effectivement elle elle profite elle
profite à qui elle profite aux
producteurs nous en france nous ne
sommes que des consommateurs des
consommateurs de pétrole des
consommateurs de gaz naturel l'heure ce
que total fait les profits il fait des
profits dans ses activités de production
en dehors de france 90 % d'activité d'au
total et or en france il est une bonne
chose d'ailleurs qu'il y est une
entreprise comme total créatrice
d'emplois en france donc quelque part
j'avoue que je ne saisis pas ce mot de
profiteurs de guerre de la même manière
que le mot de spéculateurs que nous
avons tendance à utiliser mais quelque
part nous sommes sur des marchés
totalement instable nous avons
permanence besoin de nous d'anticiper ce
que sera demain le prix du pétrole le
prix du gaz le prix du lait le prix de
l'acier et bien nous devons
anticiper et anticiper ses spéculer
alençon bombe monsieur le député nous
sommes tous de près ou de loin les
spéculateurs mais ce que nous anticipons
nous essayons d'imaginer ce que sera
demain donc il faudrait arrêter ce genre
démagogie
c'est très clair mais j'en ai demandé
qui s'en mettent pleins pleins les
poches et aurélie bon piqué les victimes
tétreault fesses je vais vous redonner
la parole philippe chalmin mais on va
faire un peu de pédagogie parce qu'il ya
des mots on voit bien que il ya aussi de
la politique derrière ces mots on va
essayer de comprendre de quoi on parle
si vous quel juillet pour distinguer
producteurs
spéculateurs distributeurs est-ce que
vous pouvez nous dire ce que recouvre
chacun de ces termes les producteurs ce
sont les pays qui produisent du pétrole
les pays les pétromonarchies des pays de
l'opep et justement les pays de l'opep
qui sont organisées dans ce qu'on
appelle un cartel c'est à dire qu'ils
vont se mettre d'accord de manière assez
régulière pour pouvoir déterminer le
nombre de quantité de barils de pétrole
qui va envoyer sur le marché le marché
hors chéquier mondial voilà et non en
fait on se rend bien compte que pour
pouvoir avoir un impact vis-à-vis de ses
marchés c'est ce qui d'ailleurs ce qu'a
souhaité faire emmanuel macron si on
veut mettre un prix maximum sur ce
marché il faut parler au niveau
international nos producteurs c'est très
clair il ya un marché du pétrole avec un
prix du baril du brent qui est fixé en
fonction de l'offre et de la demande bon
producteur c'est clair spéculateurs qui
veut répondre anne-sophie lcif est ce
qu'il y à de la spéculation pour
reprendre le marché du pétrole pour que
tout le monde voilà parle de la même
chose sur ce marché qui spécule qui
joue paris à la hausse sur ce sur ce
marché alors pour compléter par rapport
à ça en effet des spéculateurs parce que
sur les marchés de l'énergie et de
l'alimentaire comme l'a très bien
justement dit la production est
déterminé par rapport en effet un cartel
qui veut que pas trop produire pour que
des prix chutent donc on n'est pas dans
un marché normal vous avez de l'offre de
la demande et le prix la résultante de
ça je m'arrête là dessus pas trop
produire parce qu'on a on a vu un déjà
tous les les pays du g7 faire pression
sur les pays de l'opep pour leur
demander évidemment avec la guerre de
produire plus et on voit bien qu'ils
rechignent à le faire exactement un peu
plus donc déjà là on n'est pas sur un
marché classique d'offre et de demande
ouvert comme on peut la voir
économiquement les spéculateurs c'est
des personnes qui sont sur les marchés
et qui achètent les matières premières
pour le compte de tierces des sociétés
et ensuite qu'ils revendent mais eux des
personnes c'est quoi des brokers voilà
des brokers d'aider des acheteurs qui
sont sur les marchés qu'ils font pour
l'énergie mais aussi pour les denrées
alimentaires c'est important d'avoir les
deux en tête ce sont vraiment les deux
actifs où il ya en effet plus de
spéculation et donc ils peuvent
constituer des stocks quand les prix
sont bas pour pouvoir les vendre au plus
haut quand les prix en effet explose et
là en effet vous êtes sur un marché avec
un système et donc c'est très compliqué
de pouvoir réguler sa déjà vous devez
donc en effet intervenir sur les
quantités mais là en effet les prix y
sont souverains de leur décision de
production vous avez en effet des
intermédiaires qu'il a aussi travaillé
pour des sociétés au niveau
international et donc c'est très
compliqué de les réguler puisque en
effet c'est l'heure
leur travail il faut aussi dire en effet
là c'est plus haut mais par exemple en
2020 il ya aussi une crise du prix du
pétrole et il ya vraiment une chute
pourquoi parce que il n'y avait pas
assez de demande justement de pétrole et
donc stocker le pétrole était plus cher
que le prix de vente donc là le pétrole
était vendu à perte donc c'est pour ça
qu'il ya beaucoup de volatilité et qu'en
effet c'est très difficile de dire à
moyen long terme quels seront les prix
par rapport à un marché que l'acia corps
donc ces deux mamans marché classique la
main invisible
philippe chalmin qui nous écoutent il
est à distance un peu plus compliqué
vous n'avez pas l'air du tout d'accord
non je suis pas totalement d'accord
c'est malheureusement un tout petit peu
plus compliqué le gros de la spéculation
passe par les marchés financiers
et je dirais elle sert scellement de
révélateur le marché du pétrole
oui le pep l'opep plus même avec la
russie joue un certain rôle mais je
rappelle simplement que sur un marché
mondial de 100 millions barils jour
l'opep ne pèse que 30 millions de barils
jour donc quelque part
les producteurs sont des acteurs sur le
marché ils ont fit à certains moments et
il faut se dit même si ça peut paraître
un petit peu difficile à admettre que la
spéculation et les relativement neutre
on peut d'ailleurs comparé des marchés
sur le thème ya de la spéculation
financière c'est par exemple le cas du
blé il ya un marché où il n'y a pas de
spéculation financière
c'est le cas du riz la volatilité
l'instabilité présidentie à la fin du
jour le marché c'est la femme des
anticipations que l'ensemble des acteurs
peau de ce que sera demain le rapport
entre l'offre et la demande
rien n'est clair un macbook aujourd'hui
sur le marché du pétrole si je prends en
compte l'impact possible des sanctions
européennes sur la production russe la
production russe risque de diminuer et
l'autre côté on ne sait pas comment va
aller la demande en fonction du coc vide
en chine une mais globalement on peut
imaginer il y aura moins de pétrole sur
le marché et de ce fait que les prix
pourraient monter que ça nous donne
aujourd'hui 130 dollars on comprend le
bémol and social c'est stéphane peuple
nous faut réagir à cela en effet les
producteurs et donc maîtriser la
production c'est tout à fait essentielle
pourquoi à mon sens les sanctions sont
très peu efficace à la russie entre
février et juin a gagné plus de 100
milliards de dollars avec justement
l'augmentation donc bien évidemment que
ces producteurs ont intérêt à avoir la
manie de limiter la production pour
aussi avoir des prix élevés il n'y a pas
que les les spéculateurs donc ça qu'il
faut faire attention avec ces groupes
distinctes alors qu'en fait vous avez un
système global où chacun joue un rôle
identifier et à des intérêts corps avec
alors sur la question des sanctions
c'est vrai qu'à l'heure actuelle on voit
qu'elles n'ont pas porté leurs fruits
mais vont porter leurs fruits sur le
long terme parce que là on aura
évidemment une déjà on aurait une guerre
en ukraine qui va forcément
vraisemblablement se prolonger à
emmanuel macron dit clairement qu'il ya
quelque chose d'absurde qu'au fond
l'envolée des prix
voilà finances l'effort de nos jours
déjà tout à fait raison on parle quand
même d'une d'une armée russe qui a un
budget annuel de 60 milliards d'euros
hélas nos importations d'énergies
fossiles ont coûté la bagatelle de 100
milliards d'euros on se rend bien compte
en fait de la nécessité de dos plus vite
de sortir de cet engrenage des énergies
fossiles et c'est là où on peut
réfléchir aux méthodes de transition
énergétique ça c'est peut-être dans un
deuxième temps parce que l'urgence ils
permettront parle beaucoup de
l'expression du président macron mais il
ya un autre président qui a récemment à
une expression un peu similaire ces jo
bayonne en parlant en disant exxon a
gardé en parlant de la compagnie
pétrolière américaine a gagné plus
d'argent que dieu c'était sa façon à lui
de dire à peu près la même chose que ce
qu'a dit emmanuel macron donc on voit
bien qu'il ya un problème qui n'est pas
contrairement à ce qui a été dit tout à
l'heure liés aux investissements qui
sont nécessaires de la part de ses
grands groupes quand vous regardez que
quand vous voyez que total un résultat
net ça après
tout ce qu' il ya besoin comme
provisions pour anticiper l'avenir pour
investir pour mettre dans la recherche
et le développement qu'il ya un résultat
net qui est record de tous les temps
porte et qu'on atteint 16 milliards
d'euros et que à côté de ça vous avez la
masse des français qui voit le prix de
l'essence explosent et à la pompe vous
êtes obligés quand vous êtes un
responsable politique un tout petit peu
de sens et de trouver les moyens de
réguler tout cela pour alléger la
facture des français et des ménages et
en prenant tout ou partie sur les
superprofits des compagnies peuvent en
parler des solutions possibles mais
puisque vous parlez de total clément
marieke van ou dressés et bien l'état
des lieux de la situation financière les
superprofits de total vous l'avez dit
2021 ces 16 milliards d'euros liée à
l'envolée les prix des des hydrocarbures
regarder
total profite d'abord de la flambée des
cours du baril de brut le brent frôle
aujourd'hui les 115 dollars soit une
hausse de 51% en un an or les coûts de
production de total n'ont pas ou peu
augmenté sur cette même période d'où des
bénéfices records 4,9 milliards d'euros
de résultat net au premier trimestre +
46 % en un an et tout cela n'est sans
doute qu'un début total va profiter
indirectement de l'embargo européen sur
le pétrole russe
car cet embargo concerne aussi les
carburants raffinés or l'europe dépend
des du diesel russe les raffineries
européennes ont beau tourner à plein
régime elles ne peuvent pas compenser la
perte de ses importations conséquence
immédiate la marge brute de raffinage
est passé de 30 dollars la tonne au mois
de février à 153 dollars au mois de juin
de quoi gonfler un peu plus les
bénéfices du groupe pétrolier français
dans les mois à venir mais total subit
aussi les conséquences de la crise avec
la russie le groupe a provisionné plus
de 4 milliards de dollars en début
d'année car son gigantesque projet de
gaz liquéfié dans l'arctique russe
désormais menacée
s'il faut car on voit qu'il ya
énormément de levier de profits
finalement lié à la situation pour total
qui ont fondé le groupe le plus
emblématique de la situation actuelle
évidemment la raréfaction donc le prix
du pétrole qui augmentent mais aussi le
raffinage et ça c'est nouveau également
le raffinage on le sait une partie de
l'union européenne en fait avait exporté
cette activité à la russie parce que
c'était trop coûteux pour les européens
d'opérer des opérations de raffinage
donc en fait on avait demandé à la
russie de le faire et ensuite on
importait à des prix plutôt avantageux
et là on se rend compte en fait que
notre dépendance qui a été entraîné au
cours des années pour des questions en
fait de cupidité nous j'arrive à la
figure comme une bombe qui va exploser
et donc l'intérêt en réalité il est de
réfléchir à la manière dont on va
pouvoir réduire la demande pour tenter
de faire en sorte que les prix ensuite
diminue un peu naturel alors réduire la
demande ou augmenter l'offre c'est aussi
le débat c'est un élément de l'équation
quelles solutions est ce que vous pensez
déjà qu'il est possible de réguler ce
marché l'énergie alors moi je pense que
c'est très compliqué mais en effet pu
avoir un impact sur la demande si le
prix augmente trop et par rapport en
effet aux solutions au point de vue la
question est est ce qu on veut être en
effet d'un point de vue politique et
mettre un message ou être efficient
économiquement qu'est ce qui se passe
actuellement on va avoir un fort
ralentissement de la croissance cette
croissance est stimulée par la demande
qui est en général la demande des
revenus moyens ou les plus modestes avec
en effet une explosion des prix
l'énergie ce sont ces menaces qui sont
impactés et déjà qu'ils commencent à
consommer moins alors que tous les plans
de relance ont été basées sur la
consommation donc c'est pour ça que la
volonté du gouvernement de plutôt aller
sur baisse des prix à la pompe est à mon
sens plus efficient parce que ça permet
de ne pas décourager la consommation qui
est indispensable si on veut encore
garder un taux de croissance assez
satisfaisant être autour de 2 alors là
on attendait plutôt 4 et ne pas être en
récession alors j'ai vous soumettre la
phrase de bruno le maire c'est la
continuité de cette discussion qui vous
dit le ministre des finances et de
l'économie en quoi les gens père est il
moins cher leur plein d'essence si on
taxe les superprofits de total
mieux vaut une ristourne à la pompe
en fait nous propose de faire les deux
c'est à dire en fait c'est une question
de répartition des richesses tout ce que
je suis d'accord à ce que vous venez de
dire sur la consommation aujourd'hui
un plein d'un plein de 48
le réservoir moyen des véhicules un
plein tard par semaine c'est 10% d'un
smic
donc on voit bien l'impact immédiat que
ça soit la consommation des ménages
notamment des ménages modestes avec en
cascade le ralentissement de l'économie
et de la croissance donc nous nous
faisons la proposition d' avoir
momentanément pour une période de deux
ans et une deux ans et une proposition
de loi que nous déposons un début de
semaine prochaine qui a été présentée
par fabien roussel d'avoir une
proposition qui est momentanée sur deux
ans parce que derrière les coûts de
l'énergie aussi des questions liées à la
transition énergétique et sur lesquelles
il faut que du temps long mais là à
court terme ces dates de baisser la tva
de match à 5 sur les prix de deux
naissances pour avoir
supprimé la double taxe sur puisqu'il ya
la tva aussi sur la tei cpe de supprimer
cette double taxe est de financer cette
mesure au moins pour un tiers pendant
deux ans un
prélèvement de 30% soit les paroles et
les super profits ring pour total cela
représente 5 milliards donc on ne met
pas tout sur le compte de l'argent
public on fait une taxe en fait c'est
une répartition des richesses et votre
reportage disais tout à l'heure total a
beaucoup profité de leur l'embargo russe
sur le pétrole mais ça s'appelle ça à un
mot même si c'est c'est pas voulu ou
volontaire mais ces aides profiteurs de
guerre parce que bon donc alors philippe
sienne menthe juste il ya beaucoup de
propositions autour de la table met la
pression mais comment se faire respecter
pour le gouvernement c'est on sait les
moyens de contrainte pour faire baisser
les prix à la pompe on y vient passé par
une jatte 6 juste que mal à mesure que
je viens de proposer c'est 35 centimes
de moins sur le litre d'essence en haut
lieu des 12 pratiquer parole partant à
nogent d'une chose monsieur le député
qu'il est facile
voyez vous ce genre de débat n'a pas
lieu en allemagne parce que l'allemagne
n'a pas de compagnies pétrolières eux
ils ont pas totale est ce que j'imagine
quand même que vous êtes d'accord avec
moi pilier est une chance pour la france
je veux d'avoir un des majors pétroliers
au niveau mondial qui s'appelle total
alors continuez comme ça et puis un jour
les dirigeants de total abandonneront la
france et iront se mettre dans quelque
autre endroit qui finalement sera plus
intéressant il se trouve que je vous
parle du bea vous voyez vous et bien
grâce à total outre l'activité
exploration de total dans le monde est
basé à pau et c'est incontestablement le
premier rapport le premier rang anne
l'employeur palois donc très franchement
tous les ans à peu près on a droit à ce
débat sur les super profits de total à
la limite il serait peut-être mieux que
de dire on va
pas dire ça parce que d'abord c'est pas
exhaustive elle pas vrai assez lourd
premiers pois ou et n'ambitionnait pas
exact vous dites des choses qui ne sont
pas et vous répondrez vous répondrais
stephen allait déterminer
si nous n'avions pas d'autres
pétrolières on n'aurait pas se démarquer
nous consommerions quand même du pétrole
alors il met d'abord vous répondre parce
qu'on on essaye dans les conversations
non mais personne n'est là la chance
d'avoir une entreprise je recolle
d'abord l'essentiel de la fif des impôts
que paient au total il les paye ailleurs
qu'en france il est payé un pas en
france ce qui d'ailleurs est un problème
on pourrait aussi considérer que total
comme entreprise française qui bénéficie
dans son activité à l'étranger aussi de
la france de la diplomatie française du
rayonnement de la france à l'étranger
j'ai beaucoup de regrets donc pour effet
un monde en soi un moment donné quand le
marché est amoral s'il n'y a pas la
puissance publique pour mettre un peu de
régulation et ça se fait ça a été dit
tout à l'heure ça se fait en angleterre
ça se fait en italie et pourquoi ça se
ferait pas en france pourquoi la france
serait elle devenue ce pays où les super
profits deviendrai intouchable et où les
gens pourraient ne sont pas fiables
c'est le
lot rapidement parce que and social si
facebook nguyen valeur à venir
on a bon j'avoue que j'ai toujours été
réticent sur la baisse des prix à la
pompe je rappelle que 1 centimes de
baisse ça coûte 500 millions euros de
moins value fiscale et que on l'a vu
malheureusement les 18 centimes ont été
balayés par la hausse des prêts qu'on
fait raison mais que shell main pour
compte en valeur le baril proposé aucune
solution
allait me proposes tu as fait un an ça
fait un an que je propose des chèques
carburant car effectivement des gens y
sont obligés corps dont concernant les
ailes sur hd réseau national il faut le
stimuler c'est très maniable chaque
restaurant vous mettez des chèques a
bien compris c'est compliqué
c'est toujours la question qu'est-ce qui
est fille sont économiquement pour
sortir un peu du débat des fois un peu
tautologique superprofits là qui est
très politique et moins et fissures
économiquement parce que je crois en
effet très étonnant dans ce débat c'est
ce qu'on parle pas du niveau de revenu
que ce soit en effet la baisse du prix
du carburant des baisses de tva etc vous
gagner 5000 10000 euros par mois où vous
êtes au smic vous en profiter pareil
oui mais c'est un problème voire le
faire comme vous l'avez dit avec la
consommation aussi quand vous regardez
le taux d'épargné des ménages vous voyez
qu'en effet pour les revenus les plus
élevés le taux dépargne a explosé et cet
argent là reste sur les comptes et n'est
pas réinjecté dans l'économie donc se
dire vous gagné plus de 3 à 4000 euros
par mois vous allez plus payer votre
plein pour alan week-end nous faire des
choses certes c'est peut-être pas très
agréable en tout cas économiquement ça
n'a pas d'impact important je suis assez
étonné qu'il n'y ait pas toujours les
décider les revenus qu'ils soient mis en
face pour adapter les mesures parce
qu'il ya vraiment l'idée que l'énergie
augmentent donc on doit absolument et
que ce soit neutre par rapport à votre
pouvoir d'achat et trouver quelque chose
pour tout le monde quels que soient vos
revenus pour ça vous coûte rien faire
c'est la raison pour laquelle c'est pas
que ça coûte c'est la raison pour
laquelle on a dit que c'était une mesure
d'urgence
pour deux ans sachant que je vais je
m'étonne toujours que quand on augmente
la tva
ça devient un impôt juste et quand
veulent abaisser on re découvre que
c'est un impôt injuste bien sûr que
c'était un coup très injuste je voudrais
qu'on termine ce débat qui s'achève
parce qu'il nous reste une petite
poignée de deux minutes à peine
fiez-vous kings on a entendu une
pression de la république qui lui parle
d'un plafonnement des prix de l'énergie
au niveau quasiment mondiale en tout cas
européen possible ou impossible
extrêmement difficile à mettre en place
il faudrait de notre côté réunir un
cartel qui permettrait en réalité
d'imposer sa vision à l'ensemble des
producteurs d'énergie donc c'est très
dur mais pour revenir un peu sur sur le
débat des super profits on est dans une
situation exceptionnelle et à situation
exceptionnelle mesures exceptionnelles
vous parliez de l'allemagne qui n'a pas
de producteur de pétrole mais
l'allemagne commence à réfléchir à taxer
les superprofits d'être de ses
raffineries donc on se rend bien compte
que le débat commence à devenir européen
et la commission européenne s'est
positionné et a ouvert la capacité à
opérer sans qu'il faut agir à ce niveau
là lire également européen et ensuite
après ce qu'il faut faire au niveau
français sert distribuer l'ensemble de
cette taxation des supers profits aux
ménages les plus vulnérables et là on a
déjà des mesures de ciblage en place
c'est le chèque énergie c'est par
exemple pour aider les personnes à
sortir de la précarité énergétique les
chèques alimentaires pour les bleus chez
qui devrait suppléer on attend les
mesures
merci beaucoup on va s'arrêter là les
mesures sont sur la table et voyez à
votre proposition doit plier le texte
pouvoir d'achat on verra ce qu'il en est
concernant l'énergie les matières
premières précisément et la commission
donc elle par le monteur que vous allez
lancer au sein de la commission des
finances est une annonce vous avez
poussé on a notre groupe qui lance une
mission d' enquête parlementaire au
sénat et nous allons intuition remercie
le débat est donc ouvert on va le
poursuivre dans de nouvelles émissions à
venir merci aussi à philippe ciellement
merci infiniment depuis la très belle
ville de pau d'avoir été avec nous on va
à présent s'arrêter sur l'un des
événements les plus tragiques survenus
en france sous l'occupation près de
13000 juifs étrangers et français
donc quatre mille enfants arrêtées en
deux jours par la police parisienne sans
la moindre sans le moindre concours des
allemands et dont la plupart seront
exterminé à auschwitz notre grand témoin
et historien il publie un travail
remarquable sur la rafle du vel d'hiv
des 16 et 17 juin 1942 dont la france
s'apprête à commémorer les 80 en a plein
de questions à lui poser il s'appelle
laurent joly comme skis ce sujet de
marque au premier
si on vous invite laurent joly c'est
pour se plonger dans notre histoire
dans l'un des événements les plus
terribles survenus en france sous
l'occupation
la rafle du vel d'hiv 16 et 17 juillet
1942 près de 13000 juifs sont arrêtés
par la police française
53 ans plus tard jacques chirac
reconnaîtra la responsabilité de la
france un discours historique
la france ce jour là
accomplissez l'irréparable
manquant à sa parole
livré ses protégés à l'heure où laurent
joly vous êtes chercheur historien
directeur de recherche au cnrs vous êtes
un grand spécialiste du régime de vichy
et de l'extrême droite française pendant
la présidentielle vous descendez dans
l'arène politique pour contre attaquer
le candidat zemmour qui relativise le
rôle de la france et de pétain dans la
déportation des juifs c'est vrai qu'à
chaque fois qu'on lisait moore les bras
vous en tombent tellement qu'à cette
capacitéà à mentir à truquer a falsifié
loin de la falsification dans votre
dernier livre vous restituer avec
rigueur l'opération monstrueuse qui est
la rafle du vel d'hiv l'ampleur du crime
des milliers de familles arrêté entassés
dans le vélodrome d'hiver de paris avant
d'être déportés et exterminés dans le
camp d'auschwitz mais ce livre montre
aussi l'étendue de ce que nous ne
savions pas vous connaissez pas la
préparation ministre hâtives les fiches
des fichiers et la mise en oeuvre
concrète parce qu'ils étaient la police
municipale de paris viii à l'aide de
témoignages et de documents inédits de
la préfecture de police de paris vous
corriger un récit parcellaire entachée
d'erreurs apport majeur de vos
recherches l'existence d'une rafle après
la rafle et la réévaluation du nombre
d'arrestations de treize à quatorze
mille juifs c'est ça le paradoxe c'est
un semi échec on n'a jamais arrêté
autant de gens en si peu de temps en
france pendant la guerre et en même
temps on en voulait beaucoup plus alors
laurent joly la france s'apprête à
commémorer en juillet les 80 ans de la
rafle mais à l'heure où les derniers
témoins disparaissent à l'heure où les
atrocités et la cruauté semble se
répéter en ukraine cette question
pourquoi le travail de l'historien
n'empêche pas les horreurs du passé de
se reproduire
la parole
bonsoir laurent joly et merci infiniment
d'avoir accepté notre invitation donc
vous publié chez grasset cette enquête
remarquable je le disais sur la rafle du
vel d'hiv en juillet 1942 et puis vous
présenter ses dessins poignant de cabu
que cabu avait fait en 1962 il avait 27
67 il avait 29 ans et c'est aux éditions
taille ont dit on va commencer d'abord
par le fait qu'il n'a pas d'image à part
cette couverture ces quelques bus
rassemblés devant le vélodrome le
bâtiment qui a été détruit depuis c'est
la seule image qui existent de la rafle
comment l'expliquez comment expliquer
d'abord on a vu dans le reportage qui a
des photos qui circulent voilà et
souvent on dit ça elle représente la
rafle du vél disent non ils représentent
d'autres raffoux parfois même c'est des
choses qui n'ont rien à voir avec la les
arrestations de juifs alors en 41 on
avait beaucoup d'image parce que les
allemands se disait on va faire de la
propagande autour des premières rafles
mais on arrêter des hommes ou les
envoyer dans des camps en france donc
pouvait commencer acclimater la
population à l'antisémitisme et en 1942
ils ont renoncé à faire ça parce que on
arrête des femmes des enfants et les
allemands tout de suite compris en zone
occupée que la population n'adhérez pas
donc la seule photo qui a été conservée
site une photo de presse celle que vous
voyez en couverture du livre paris le
journal paris midi et au verso de 7,2
cette photo je publie le document petite
légende photo il ya une petite légende
on va voir ça boit une petite légende
antisémites et on voit que la censure
allemande refuse la publication de cette
photo est d'ailleurs va donné comme mot
d'ordre à la presse en zone occupée de
ne pas absolument pas évoqué ce qui
s'est passé donc ya pas un mot sur la
rafle du vel d'hiv qui était pourtant
une opération publique n'a pas un mot
dans la presse oui ça va durer des
années 1 alors la spécificité de cette
énorme opération policière c'est des
enfants alors je voudrais qu'on s'arrête
là dessus il ya quatre mille cinq cents
policiers mobilisés par rené bousquet le
chef de la police du régime de vichy
vous avez énormément travaillé sur les
documents administratifs sur les filles
chez les fichiers de juifs qui ont été
recensés 8000 hommes et femmes polonais
pour la plupart mais aussi quatre mille
enfants le plus souvent français lui
alors la rafle du vel d'hiv et à la base
un arrangement criminelle entre
l'occupant et vichy vichy accepte de
livrer des dizaines de milliers de juifs
en robes vichy dit aux allemands va vous
donner le nombre de juifs étrangers que
vous voulez ces appareils qui a le plus
de juifs et donc c'est là qu'on organise
la plus grosse opération en a sorti 27
mille 400 fiches mais ça concerne que
des juifs et juive de plus de 16 ans il
ya les enfants alors les enfants les
allemands sont pas très claires les
amendes sont pas très claires ils disent
on veut d'abord des juifs en âge de
travailler et les enfants bon ben on les
prendra plus tard bon
la réalité c'est qu'en fait à auschwitz
on ne peut pas encore voilà utiliser les
crématoires à plein rendement d'envoyer
une raison cynique qui explique cette
espèce de mystère qui fait que
normalement les enfants auraient dû être
séparés de leurs parents dès le moment
de l'arrestation est confié à
l'assistance publique voilà et c'est pas
ce qui va se passer c'est ce qui va se
passer en province mais c'est pas ce qui
va se passer à paris parce qu'à paris
sur les vingt-sept mille 400 fiches
arrestation on va en exécuter la police
parisienne va en exécuter que 9000 c'est
un paradoxe qui était signalé en
ouverture c'est c'est à la fois le la
plus grosse opération qui évoluent en
europe de l'ouest il n'y a jamais une
opération plus et en même temps c'est un
semi échec les allemands on attendait
beaucoup les enfants d'attendre beaucoup
en eau dont on entend des dc a quand
même été voilà a fait du zèle les
circulaires sont très sévères tant que
demain voilà et le résultat n'est pas
celui auquel on s'attendait et on a en
plus on a neuf mille ans n'a que 9 1000e
juifs et juive en âge de travailler et
on se retrouve à quatre mille enfants
sur les bras c'est beaucoup c'est aussi
des scènes déchirantes moment des
arrestations donc là on se dit il vaut
mieux les laisser avec leurs parents et
les envoyer dans les camps du loiret à
pithiviers et beaune-la-rolande où
normalement devait commencer à déporter
les parents et les enfants devaient
rester à paris et en fait non tout le
monde va partir là bas mais quand même
les allemands n'en veulent pas d'où ce
chaos j'ai un chapitre s'intitule le
chaos parce que en fait on se rend
compte qu'on est dans un engrenage
criminel et plus personne ne peut en
sortir est normalement vous l'avez
signalé ces enfants en fait sont
français à 80% d'entre eux ils font sont
français titre définitif dire que
normalement il était libérable et
d'ailleurs quand les autorités du loiret
se retrouve avec ses 4000 enfants
existent mais non il pourrait sortir et
non ils peuvent pas les sortir c'est
trop compliqué d'ailleurs choqué
tellement l'opinion que c'est la seule
fois que ça va se produire devant
l'histoire de la guerre la séparation
des parents des enfants et leur
extermination c'est un deal monstrueux
qui a été passé entre l'état français
collaborateurs et l'occupant nazi vous
expliquez bien que l'état français dit
si vous voulez en faire cette rafle une
opération de souveraineté nationale
il ne voulait pas que les allemands s'en
occupe j alors cette logique la quête
une logique technocratique qui est très
importante pour le chef de la police
rené bousquet vient se greffer sur les
deux logiques principales qui sont
celles de la collaboration en juillet 42
ans dit convaincu encore à vichy calm
and a gagné la guerre donc il faut
livrer maximum de juifs parce que c'est
bien pour alimenter la politique de
collaboration il ya aussi une
antisémitisme propres de vichy qui
depuis 1940 à l'intention de se
débarrasser des juifs étrangers selon
les juifs étrangers de paris c'est pas
les réfugiés qui sont dans les camps de
zone libre sont des immigrés en
situation régulière
donc on va expulser des gens qui sont
des gens en voilà que n'aurait pas sur
mêlée parfois apatrides certains vous
montrer qu' ils ont été naturalisés
français on leur retire exactement ya
plusieurs centaines de juifs qui sont
qui sont visés par la raf et qui on est
et on le voit sur sur ses fiches qui ont
été des naturalisés par vichy qui de ce
fait sont arrêtés alors on voit très
bien à travers tous ces documents
administratifs arrondissement par
arrondissement
les agissements des policiers il y en a
qui font des excès de zèle le
commissaire tueur chaussures power-pop
vous décrivez il y en a qui disent non
enfin en tout cas qu'ils appliquent avec
plus de souplesse les consignes et ça il
y a des marges de manoeuvre le nom du
demandeur
d'abord parce que c'est la première fois
qu'on fait ça qu'on va arrêter comme ça
des femmes et des enfants au petit matin
on l'a jamais fait donc il déjà rien que
dans les circulaires et déjà des petits
problèmes des contradictions on n'a pas
pensé à tout et après eh bien les
exécutants ils ont des marges que vous
avez cité l'exemple des commissaires qui
est très important parce que ce sont eux
qui sont les chevilles ouvrières de la
rafle dans son exécution enfin certains
vont commenter d'autres vont pas
commenté et certains vont commenter en
disant il faut y aller dur parce que
c'est important pour le gouvernement
c'est important pour les allemands et
d'autres vont dire c'est pas notre
boulot n'a pas de rang loin faire ça
mais on nous a demandé de le faire donc
on le fait mais on agit de manière
humaine et vous montrer qu'il y avait
des exemptions aussi ont fait en tout
cas des catégories dans les documents
les personnes par exemple qui était
infirme alors elle aussi pourtant n'ont
pas été épargnés il ya vraiment au fond
une sorte d'application au cas par cas
selon chaque individu dans les
arrondissements qui vont appliquée
différemment
après au niveau des équipes
d'arrestations ben qu'est ce qu'on fait
quand même porte est close est ce qu'on
la défonce ou pas ou pas donc il ya des
offres même pas la concierge est
persuadé qu' à personne il ya des
commissaires qu'ils font défoncer les
portes des agents qui vont prendre sur
eux de le faire et des agents qui vont
laisser filer et les infirmes les
infirmes qu'est-ce qu'on en fait
normalement naissance et les amener mais
certains policiers vont se dire quand
même nom il a des décorations et il ya
certains qui vont pas être arrêté
certains enfants auraient pu être
épargnées à cette circulaire qui ordonne
l'arrestation de toutes les femmes ayant
un enfant de plus de deux ans c'est à
dire nés avant le 1er juillet 1940 et là
c'est terrible quand on se figure les
choses deux ans est terrible il révélé
vous avez des policiers qui même si on
est à deux ans et deux jours hexal ont
arrêté d'autres exactement le contraire
tout à fait vous avez cité l'exemple du
commissaire turpault qui là tu vas tu
intransigeant c'est ses équipes viennent
l'idée d'une veulent voir mais y'a un
garçon il est né le 21 juin 1940 ce
qu'on pourrait pas le nom on le prend et
d'autres qui vont dire bon méline en
avril il est né c'est un bébé il a que
deux ans donc on l'a on le laisse avec
ça l'un des apports de cette enquête
historique c'est aussi que vous montrer
qu'il ya d'autres rafle après la rafle
il ya des brigades spécialisées qui vont
arrêter après fait un rap de 1942 puis à
lorsque j'ai découvert ça c'est vraiment
grâce aux dossiers d'épuration j'ai pu
consulter g consulter l'intégralité des
dossiers d'épuration 4000 et j'ai trouvé
plusieurs centaines de dossiers qui
documents dossiers qui documentent 7
rafah après la rave en fait comme il ya
plus de quinze mille personnes qui n'ont
pas été trouvés au moment des
arrestations eh ben on a on a gardé les
filles dans les commissariats et on a
constitué des équipes de la police
municipale qui ont continué en fait à la
raf donc on retourne chez les gens on
essaye de voir s'ils reviennent ou pas
alors je vous propose à présent de
parler de ce travail
r de cabu que vous présentez dans cet
album chez taillandier on est très très
loin évidemment de ses croquis d'humour
il a 29 ans nous sommes en 1967 et il
décide de dessiner ce que jacques chirac
a appelé après l'irréparable
on va regarder quelques uns mais d'abord
expliquez nous comment est né ce projet
de cabu alors se pencher de cas bus il
vient d'en livre en 1967 il ya un
premier livre qui sort ce d'un livre qui
est fondée sur des témoignages la grande
rafle du vel d'hiv il sait aussi un
livre qui veut vraiment
révéler la vérité sur l'histoire parce
qu'elle sait rien et paul tia pas
historien que le débit il est il et on
le confond souvent avec un autre défi
qui historiens mais lui c'est un médecin
et paul tear c'était un romancier ce
sont d'anciens militants communistes qui
ont rompu avec le parti commises sur 56
et qui reste des militants de la mémoire
de la résistance et de ce qui est arrivé
aux juifs et pour claude davis est très
important que cette histoire là soient
connus du grand public à l'époque elle
ne l'est pas du tout et donc ce livre va
faire un effet de révélation il ya
magazine gq le nouveau candidat qui
décide de faire
depuis les bonnes feuilles comme on
disait et qui va sur quatre numéros
publiés
pratiquement la moitié du livre de
claude davy épaules tillard et ils vont
demander à cabu est un jeune dessinateur
de 29 ans qui déjà un petit peu connu
mais qui est pas évidemment les normes
vedette qu'il va devenir dans les 110 80
de l'illustré leur cabine qui travaille
déjà pour pour pilotes pour hara kiri
mais contribua au figaro fin dans plein
de journaux et donc ils acceptent de
faire ce reportage
et il va le faire de manière extrêmement
sensible il n'y a pas une once d'humour
il n'y a pas une once d'ironie il est
avec les victimes et autour des victimes
on voit d'ailleurs qu'à kehl sur les
dessins à les regarder ses défunts voilà
il ya quelques dessins contre
l'arrestation d'abord c'est la
couverture de cet album
dessins des parents arrêté la main sur
la tête on le voit à l'antenne avec
cette petite fille on clair obscur caché
sous un porche une une petite poupée à
la main sont magnifiques ce tous ces
dessins puis on va on va vous montrer
comment et ça c'est extraordinaire comme
encas but imagine l'enfer du vel d'hiv
car on l'a dit n'y a aucune image le
bâtiment a été détruit voilà ce dessin
des milliers et des milliers d'hommes et
de femmes en détresse avec une
foultitude de détails on le voit c'est
incroyable ce dessin c'est comme si au
fond il nous permettait de devoir celui
mort alors évidemment à l'époque en 1967
on ne sait on ne sait pas tout par
exemple les victimes n'était pas
rassemblé sur le terre-plein central les
victimes étaient uniquement dans les
gradins sauf les malades il y avait des
tentes de la croix rouge mais voilà lui
il se fonde sur à l'époque il y avait
une photo on pensait qu'elle
représentait et non elle représentait d
épurer en grand en 44 au foyer mais
malgré tout ce qu'il a réussi a
extrêmement bien saisir c'est la
détresse de ces familles on voit que
sont toujours rassemblés en petits
cercles qui a pas de solidarité entre
les gens les gens sont complètement
abattus sont complètement perdus et se
replie sur l'eau sur leur cercle
familial on voit plein de petites
saynètes comme ça qui sont
bouleversantes des gens qui sont pris de
folie qu'il faut attacher sur des
brancards une tentative de suicide donc
voilà il a essayé à partir des
témoignages qui étaient disponibles 67
de représenter ce drame l'autobus ces
bus à plateforme plein à craquer avec la
préfecture qui en avaient réquisitionné
mais voilà le bus une cinquantaine
chaque visage on les voit montre la peur
la résignation l'abattement il faut
expliquer que voilà dans ces bus ces
juifs arrêtés passé par le vel d'hiv
vont vers drancy ou pithiviers avant
d'être ce qu'ils se voyaient dans les
trains d'abord on les a menés dans des
centres de rassemblement et puis après
en bus on les a conduits ça représente
le convoiement des personnes arrêtées
soit vers level 10 et leur on a mis les
familles et les adultes directement des
portables on les avait amenés
directement à drancy d'envoyer les deux
circuits les 16 et 17 juillet 42 et puis
les trains wagon rempli de femmes s'est
investi un poignant parce que y'a que
des femmes des mères à qui les enfants
étaient arrachés voilà ce dessin avec ce
soldat
allemand qui va refermer le wagon en
route vers les camps de la mort vous
avez vous lu dans ce travail
d'accompagnement expliqué parce qu'on va
commémorer les 80 ans à tous ces jeunes
qui ne connaissent pas expliquez-nous
comment ils gèrent ce projet au fond
d'accompagner ses débuts véronique cabu
vous tenez absolument la femme de cabu à
ce que ces dessins soient montrés au
plus grand nombre d'où une exposition
qui est au mémorial de la shoah à partir
d'aujourd'hui 1er juillet et qui est
vraiment destiné au plus grand nombre et
notamment aux lycéens pour ça qu'elle va
continuer jusqu'au 7 novembre avec des
dessins qui sont d'ailleurs extrêmement
bien exposé on a des originaux et on les
voit en grand format et donc on peut
vraiment se plonger dans les
reproductions cc c'est tout à fait
fascinant et le livre lui vraiment
destinée à expliquer de manière très
pédagogique les différentes étapes de la
raf ça commence avec les arrestations et
la dernière image c'est celle ci c'est
ce qu'on voit du 3 août 942 c'est la
dislocation des familles on a déporté
d'abord les pères et ensuite le 3 août
de pithiviers en des portes les maires
n'y a quasiment que des femmes dans ce
convoi et on le sait que quinze jours
après ce sera les enfants qui seront
après avoir subi cette détresse de la
solitude qui seront envoyées devanciers
déportés je suis avec les commémorations
j'imagine auquel vous avez peut-être été
associés pour pour le 16 juillet de 17
juillet prochain dernière question elle
vous êtes est posée au tout début de ce
sujet par marco pommier comment le
travail de l'historien peut contribuer à
empêcher d'une certaine façon les
horreurs de l'histoire de se répéter à
l'heure de la guerre en ukraine déjà ce
que le l'historien peut faire c'est
d'empêcher les contre vérités sur ces
sujets là de prospérer vous avez cité
tout à l'heure selon le livre que j'ai
fait qu'on vaut pour critiquer les
propos d'eric zemmour voilà au moins on
peut déjà essayé de faire ça parce que
le discours de jacques chirac qui était
un acquis ben perry zemmour annoncé que
si lui été pris dans la république il
reviendrait surviendrait voc voilà la
vérité de l'histoire est fragile et
qu'il faut sans cesse la répéter merci
infiniment merci beaucoup l'angel il est
repassé par le plateau de lcp on va
terminer avec nos a franchi deux
chroniques ce soir brandon warhead qui
revient sur ces président de la
commission des finances
à l'assemblée qui ont marqué l'histoire
du parlement et puis tibre enoch
thibault qui nous pas ce soir de la
contraception hier aujourd'hui demain à
l'heure où le droit à l'avortement a été
révoqué et les états unis nos a franchi
au masculin est en pleine forme je
l'espère bonsoir bonsoir brandon bonsoir
thibault va commencer avec vous brandet
on a beaucoup parlé de l'élection d'eric
coquerel nouveau président de la
commission des finances ici à
l'assemblée nationale on le sait le
règlement maintenant fait que ce poste
stratégique revient à un manque
d'opposition poids de l'opposition alors
vous vous êtes intéressé aux différents
présidents des commissions des finances
par le passé ça n'a pas toujours été le
cas d'ailleurs il n'a pas toujours été
un opposant au gouvernement mais non
puisque cette règle est très récente
elle a été introduite en 2007 par
nicolas sarkozy alors tout juste
président de la république puis intégré
officiellement en 2009 dans le règlement
de l'assemblée nationale avant cela
c'était naturellement la majorité qui ne
l'est le ton est en 1959 pour présider
la première commission des finances de
l'assemblée sous la vème république la
majorité gaulliste place à sa tête un
ancien ministre et parlementaire
aguerris c'est paul reynaud c'est un
habitué de la maison et vous vous être
sûr qu'à la cantine du palais bourbon
lui paul reynaud a son rond de serviette
puisqu'il est réélue pour la troisième
fois d'affilée président de la
commission des finances a plus de 80 ans
et lorsque le gouvernement est sur le
point de mener une vaste réforme fiscale
même à 80 ans paul reynaud n'a pas perdu
ses réflexes pour passer de la pommade
dans le dos des français écoutez le
pendant toute ma carrière je n'ai jamais
vu une réforme transports - brusquement
à la fiscalité salon donc les fortes
comme dans la commission des finances et
du gouvernement
enfin la personnages qu'à toute la
sympathie du président de la commission
des finances
ce héros méconnu le contribuable
français
alors on va enchaîner avec michel
d'ornano oui en 1981 alors les
socialistes au pouvoir perde les
législatives du mois de mars grâce à une
coalition entre le rpr et l'udf qui
obtient la majorité à l'assemblée
s'ouvre alors la première cohabitation
jacques chirac devient premier ministre
et nomme à la tête de la présidence des
commissions des finances un baron l'udf
donc michel d'ornano sauf que c'est la
crise au sein de la majorité de
l'assemblée un socialiste roland dumas a
été élu président de la commission des
affaires étrangères en cause le candidat
de la majorité bernard stasi a été trahi
par un vote anonyme au sein de son
propre camp suivre ce qui forcément
l'empêchent de l'emporter alors
forcément vous connaissez le tempérament
de michel d'ornano il est remonté et
voilà qu'il se transforme en australie
mus et bien écoutez c'est ça la majorité
n'a qu'à continuer comme ça et moi je
peux vous donner le nom du prochain
président de la république
française traite pas son nom mais en
tout cas son parti ce sera le candidat
du parti socialiste
si on continue comme ça ma michel dans
l'amour est il des dons de voyance deux
ans plus tard le candidat du parti
socialiste françois mitterrand est réélu
président de la république comme il
l'avait prédit alors justement la
nouvelle commission des finances à
l'assemblée se retrouve aussi à ce
moment là des couleurs socialistes c'est
seulement la seconde fois qu'un
socialiste est élu à la tête de la
commission des finances après christian
goux en 1981 et cette fois c'est un
socialiste encore méconnu à l'époque un
ancien professeur d'économie j'ai nommé
dominique strauss kahn et oui dominique
strauss kahn et vous verrez en 1989 le
nouveau président de la commission des
finances défend et mes yeux une mesure
qui va finir par voir le jour près de 30
ans plus tard en 2018 c'est un
visionnaire
avec notre système les décisions qu'on
prend n'ont d'effet que sur l'année
suivante puisque en fait on paye
aujourd'hui des l'impôt sur les revenus
de l'année passée tandis qu'avec un
système de retenue à la source comme
céline médias la conséquence est
immédiate et donc comme instrument de
politique économique c'est mieux
formidable archives avant ça on appelait
ça le stockage à la source sa date de
l'époque de vichy et c'est valéry
giscard d'estaing qui lui a relancé le
débat en 1973 par la commission des
finances sert souvent aussi de
marchepied à ses présidents dominique
strauss kahn abandonne en 1991 la
présidence et obtient le portefeuille de
ministre
de l'industrie du commerce quant à henri
emmanuelli son successeur à la
présidence il se contentera de du marche
au pied de la présidence de l'assemblée
nationale hier soir et l'arrière d'actes
mans le perchoir et de deux autres
présidences la commission des finances
c'est un record dans l'histoire
maintenant reste à savoir ce que nous
procure et monsieur eric coquerel dans
les années qui suivent oui on verra s'il
a le même destin que ses prédécesseurs
merci beaucoup aux des archives de
brandon ouaret on continue d'ailleurs
d'une certaine façon en archives mais
pas seulement avec thibaut ce soir
voyage dans le temps vous nous parler de
la contraception et oui car vous avez
certainement entendu parler de ces vents
mauvais qui nous viennent des états unis
après l'avortement remise en cause par
la cour suprême c'est la contraception
qui serait dans le viseur du doyen des
juges américains le juge clarence thomas
ce dans un avis personnel rendu en marge
de la décision de la cour sur les vg cet
ultraconservateur écrit qu'il souhaite
revenir sur la législation concernant le
droit à la contraception datant de 1965
dans l'esprit de ce juge le droit à la
contraception n'est pas explicitement
protéger dans la constitution américaine
et peut donc être remise en cause des
débats compenser d'un autre temps mais
qui reviennent dans l'actualité sous nos
yeux médusés malheureusement alors on va
regarder dans le rétroviseur c'est la
tradition de cette chronique comment ses
droits aujourd'hui remise en cause ont
été montés laitiers ati il est d'autant
plus dommageable que cet obscurantisme
ressurgissent aux etats-unis que ce pays
était le pionnier de la contraception
revenons en
1956 outre atlantique cette année là le
médecin et biologiste gregory pincus met
au point une combinaison de progestérone
et d'oestrogène de synthèse la première
pilule contraceptive pour femmes aînées
elle est baptisée hainaut vide sa
commercialisation aux états unis sera
autorisée en 1960 ça c'est pour la
découverte scientifique mais on l'a
compris la contraception c'est aussi une
affaire politique et sur ce point c'est
une femme qui va jouer un rôle central
la voici elle s'appelle estelle grise
vol de militante des droits civiques et
féministe en 1961 elle ouvre un centre
de planning familial dans le connecticut
et elle se voit attaqué par l'état pour
délivrance illégal de contraceptifs elle
est d'abord condamné mais elle porte la
faire devant la cour suprême et celle ci
lui donnera raison
en 1965 autorisant ainsi la
contraception au niveau fédéral c'est la
viguerie ce vol contre connecticut et
c'est cet avis que le juge thomas
aimerait remettre en couple en france
alors comment ça fait cette conquête
alors avec un temps de retard par
rapport aux états unis il faut dire que
la france après-guerre continuer de
vivre sous le coup d'une loi datant de
1920 une loi qui était destiné à
favoriser la natalité après la saignée
de 14-18 et qui interdisait non
seulement l'avortement mais aussi la
contraception et ce qui était appelé la
propagande anticonceptionnelle il faut
attendre 1967 pour que cette loi soit
abrogée et que la contraception soit
légalisé en france et la loi neuwirth la
loi est votée à l'assemblée à l'issue
d'un intense combat combat pour la
liberté des femmes résumé par une de ses
défenseurs écouter pour nous le problème
est que le fait que les femmes doivent
avoir le droit d'avoir ou de ne pas
avoir les enfants et d'en avoir le
l'ombre qui leur paraît souhaitable et à
l'époque où elle les désirs normalement
une femme un envie d'avoir des enfants
si on veut vraiment donner la liberté
aux femmes d'avoir des enfants ou de ne
pas en avoir les avoir quand elle le
désire eh bien il est indispensable de
prendre parallèlement à l'abrogation de
la loi de 1920 des mets des mesures qui
permettent que le choix soit réellement
libres alors cette loi sera complétée
quelques années plus tard en 1974 par
une nouvelle loi à l'initiative de
simone veil loi qui permet cette fois le
remboursement de la pilule par la
sécurité sociale une histoire qui
continue de s'écrire un l'an dernier le
gouvernement a fait voter la gratuité de
la pilule pour toutes les femmes de
moins de 25 ans mesure entrée en vigueur
le 1er janvier dernier et demain alors
comment pourrait-elle s'écrire cette
histoire est bien celle s'écrivait au
masculin cette histoire myriam à travers
l'histoire c'est la femme qui a porté
l'essentiel de la charge de la
contraception l'avenir pourrait être de
rendre cette charge plus égalitaire mais
pour et voilà il faut de nouveaux moyens
contraceptifs pour les hommes beaucoup
de choses sont à l'étude la pilule
effectivement vous le dit en réalité ça
fait des années que les scientifiques
travaillent dessus mais jusqu'ici avec
des résultats insatisfaisants ça
pourrait changer avec
deux avancées qui viennent d'être
réalisés des chercheurs américains ont
mis au point une pilule hormonal qui
empêcherait la production de
spermatozoïdes mais n'impliquerait que
peu ou pas d'effets secondaires
indésirables ce qui était jusqu'ici le
problème autre technologie une pilule
cette fois non hormonal à base de
protéines elle vient d'être testé avec
succès sur des souris où elle a été
efficace à 99 % pour prévenir les
grossesses et les chercheurs espèrent
une mise sur le marché d'ici cinq ans il
faut la tester sur les humains
évidemment effet avant en attendant
d'autres solutions sont en développement
regarder pour finir celle ci c'est une
invention allemande alors qu'elle n'est
pas question de pilule mais d'un bain
testiculaire alors ça peut prêter à
sourire mais c'est sérieux mais rien
alors messieurs voici le mode d'emploi
vous mettez un peu d'eau dans ce petit
récipient connectés qui va la faire
chauffer puis vous proposez à vos
parties intimes de prendre un bon bain
quelques minutes suffisent pour que
grâce à la chaleur et à des ultrasons
vos spermatozoïdes soit neutralisée
pendant 15 jours alors rassurons-nous
cependant camarades masculins nous
envoie encore un petit peu de temps pour
nous préparer écologie c'est pas sûr que
cette innovation énorme succès merci
beaucoup hier aujourd'hui demain j'ai
appris beaucoup de chose merci à vous
deux thibault enock et brandon ouaret
c'est la fin de cette émission je vous
souhaite un excellent week end à la
semaine prochaine
[Musique]